In other words, you are the
villain who deceived His Majesty the King of our country and
even
cut off his arm.
But
this question
was a hit, so the circumstances have
changed.
After all,
if this woman is a bottomless threat,
then come on. The moment you touch this wall, just like that knight and
the king, your
arms and legs will disappear as if they were torn apart.
It's probably the annihilation effect that erases anything you touch.I can understand
why you can see this wall.It seems that the
whole body is covered with light,
so the power is diffused.If you
concentrate on one point, the effect will be even better.  It should.
[MUSIC] Can you
believe it? You're a
Highlander Arklord, you're
surprisingly timid. Sounds good
[MUSIC] I
hope you're not a coward.
With the blow that accompanies it
destroys the very structure of magic.